MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, special relativity.
In this video, we talk about
Galilean transformation.
So what is it
you're going to do?
We want to describe
our event P, maybe
Professor Klute exploding, with
two different reference frames.
We can call one of the reference
frames our laboratory frame.
Maybe that's the frame in which
Professor Klute was stationary.
It has an origin and
has axis x, y, and z.
And then we have a
moving frame, which
is moving with a constant
velocity with respect
to the laboratory frame.
The origin is o prime.
The axes are x prime,
y prime, and z prime.
All right, so now what
do we learn from this?
Let's think about an example.
An example most of
you have experienced
before is the one where
you sit in a train car.
And, if it's not a train car,
it can be a car or a plane,
something which is moving
with respect to Earth.
If you look out of the
window and the acceleration
is very, very minor,
it's often not clear
whether or not the Earth, the
train station, or the train car
is moving.
And so you have this kind of
weird feeling that, you know,
I don't know if maybe the
neighboring train started
moving or I'm moving.
But what we're
going to do here is
describe you sitting
in the train car,
reading a newspaper, once
within your laboratory frame,
within the frame of
the train, and then we
want to describe the very
same events or sequence
of events in the frame of
the stationary train station.
All right, let's look
at a specific example.
Here again our professor
is exploding at a time tP
at xP, yP, and zP.
To make this a little bit
easier, we define, at time t
equals 0, the origin of
the two frames coincide.
That just means
that, at the origin,
we have two clocks, two watches.
And we make sure that
they're synchronized.
And then my watch stays with
me, and then the second watch
may be with you,
which moves along.
And those are great watches.
They are synchronized.
We also want to
simplify-- we can always
define the direction of
our coordinate system
such that the velocity,
the relative velocity
between the two
reference frames,
is in one specific direction.
And here I decided to use x.
I could have used y
and z, and I could
rotate the coordinate systems
or the relative movement
of the coordinate
systems in any way.
It's just a simplification here.
When I do that, I can
rewrite this event P
in the S prime frame through the
S frame in the following way.
So, for x, we find that xP is
given by-- x prime P is given
by xP minus v, the velocity,
relative velocity--
I could put a little
label x here--
times tP.
And then, for the y-coordinates
and the z-coordinates,
there's no change.
For the time, intuitively,
you say that those two watches
are run with the
same speed, meaning
that the time in both frames for
the same events are the same.
So now I'm asking you, if
you're watching this video,
to find the velocity
and the acceleration.
It might be good to stop
and just write this down.
So find the velocity and
acceleration of S prime,
of S prime expressed
by the S-coordinates.
So let's try to do that.
So, first, we build the
derivative dx prime dt prime,
which is our velocity.
That's the velocity of an
object in my prime frame.
And that's given by d dt--
I can just do that here because
the times are the same--
times x minus vt.
That's [? x, ?] ux, the
velocity in my S frame,
minus v. That's really
what you expect.
You just subtract or
add the velocities.
If I then build
the acceleration,
I have to build the
derivative of u x prime, which
is our acceleration,
in the prime frame.
Here again I just do
this in x-direction
because the solution for the
y-direction and z-direction
are trivial.
So now I find d
ux dt minus dv dt.
Now, the velocity,
as we defined,
between the two reference
frames is constant.
Therefore, this is 0,
meaning that the velocity--
the accelerations in the
two frames are the same.
If the accelerations
are the same,
that means that the forces in
the two frames are the same.
And that means that the
forces or the accelerations
are invariant.
They do not change based on
the reference frame that I use.
So now, coming
back to the example
we discussed in our
very first lecture,
you are experiment
in the train car.
S, the velocity between
those two frames,
the frame in your car or a
second frame, are constant.
There's no way to tell
whether or not your train
car is moving or not.
That is only true as
long as the velocities
are constant and
unchanged, constant.
So, in summary, in
Newton's mechanics,
time and accelerations are
invariant and, therefore,
also the forces.
There is no inertial frame
which is above another one.
So you can pick one or
can pick another one.
There's no difference in the
descriptions of the physics
between those two frames.